stop yawning oops it's bad for camera
hey guys I'm Greg
well I'm John it's John it's a 1:00 in
the morning right now
just got back from watching the nice
guys we were gonna shoot a review for
that but we figured Star Trek beyond
trailer dropped while we were in the
theaters so huh we'd rather do that cuz
let's face it which video is gonna get
more views right marketing I thought the
Star Trek beyond trailer the first one
um was fantastic universally receipt
everyone was really everyone was really
on board sab so now I really feel like
this next trailer has really you know
they set the bar over the last ones we
can get a good brass monkey going on
it's gonna be good yeah I'm like I love
that I love how they use that song yeah
BC boys perfect this and the
Ghostbusters Tyler with the strong if
you didn't I was so excited it's been
approved no good
my dad joined Starfleet because he
believed in it
I joined on a dare you joined to see if
you could live up to him yes sure
you spent all this time trying to be a
father
so the first one naughty wondering just
what it means to me you
it isn't uncommon you know it's easy to
get lost
in the vastness of space
there's only yourself your sheep
here crew I really want to head back out
there huh
very scary beautiful
what the hell is this
aborting us yeah
that's all y'all
I know why you here while we are all
here our captain will come to us mercy
will be the last thing on his mind I am
bound to on
fear death is illogical
fear of death is what keeps us alive
everyone who goes there he kills that's
how friends are there we can't just
leave him behind
shoulda cheeks ducks your strength it's
a weakness I think you're under
estimating humanity hold on to something
we'll do it
Courtney you better smack that [ __ ] in
the face no [ __ ] out of the captaincy
movie starring a shotgun yeah cuz he
beats woman let's be clear there is no
way that trailer was better than the
last one let it sink in feel those
people closing out the video and leaving
a comment ya know that trailer was
better than the last one yeah it
definitely had more of a Star Trek
flavor to it for the beginning I'd say
for most I say like my least in tone
with the with the last two movies you
know we yeah yeah overall like okay
here's a plot than shit's gonna get
[ __ ] insane the us Enterprise and USS
yeah right oh [ __ ] USS yes night it's
Jade's service enterprise it looks like
it's getting all the things done right
but you want for a summer blockbuster
you know it's yeah it's got cool effects
it looks like there's gonna be some fun
thrills humor and it's not really
present in this trailer I like that
there's humor in the first and second
Star Trek and I hope that this film has
I'm sure will it's from the guy who
directed like several The Fast and
Furious movies one thing though is I
couldn't help but watch it and be like
this feels like a part three in a film
of like a franchise which was like seven
films and this is like but what happened
the third one again and then you have
this sequel so it's like it's not bad I
don't feel like it's gonna be bad but I
I don't feel like it's gonna be
memorable if that makes sense I could be
totally wrong shizzle it's just the
second trailer out of like an epic Star
Trek movie just so far from the two
trailers I'm like yeah this looks like a
fun sequel you know into darkness the
way they represented that I really felt
like oh this isn't necessary next
journey you know this one I feel like
they cooked up a sequel I don't know I
was interested in the first half cuz
they were doing all that like you know
ah Kirk
you have to learn yourself and you know
all this
yeah why did you join and sort of you
know self questioning things and it was
like a little more intellectual method
that was cool and then the second half
the trail is just [ __ ] crazy action I
mean that's not a problem into darkness
I really love the first Star Trek movie
that JJ Abrams did into darkness I went
for the ultimate viewing experience I
went to IMAX I had sent receipt IMAX
perfect seat I know what number it is a
Universal CityWalk
visually it was really cool but I felt
like there's a lot of hisses like mainly
action company huh I want Star Trek II
know and from what Simon Pegg was
talking about in articles I've read
about how he was working on the Star
Trek 3 script about how you know it is
gonna go back to that more that you know
exploratory kind of beyond you know sort
of world as opposed to just some really
cool action scenes in space you know
yeah I do get the gripe that I feel like
some Star Trek fans have work it's like
it's kind of become Star Wars with all
the crazy action the things blowing up
in space even though they had action in
Star Trek they had adventure it wasn't
like well starch which started off as a
television destruction yeah sorry Trek
started off as a television series you
know yeah so on a television medium at
the time it came out you couldn't make a
show that was primarily action yes good
you had to tell a story with like cool
like sci-fi things going on and that's
what I really hope this goes back to you
know cuz I I thought the first one had a
pretty good blend with a modern-day
audience of a good amount of action plus
like story and he dealt with the
timeline while fun [ __ ] and it was cool
it's exciting it was really fun and the
second one I felt was more just the
becoming just a summer blockbuster and
so far we're seeing from this it does
feel like just a summer blockbuster when
what makes Star Trek so good is like the
character journey is the adventures they
go on not so much the spectacle but we
really get hooked in these characters in
the Star Trek world I would like to see
some character like better character
moments and some of these trailers you
know yeah because this trailer looks
like it has the potential to either be
like surprisingly good or you know just
another kind of super serious big
spectacle movie I don't think it's gonna
be super serious it's hard to tell what
this movie's gonna be especially cuz we
have two very different trailers one's
like trying to capture the the Wonder
again and stuff and then the last ones
like look at look cool Star Trek Xena
listen guys if you're new to the channel
you want to go to a place you've never
been boldly before no that's how it goes
right
oh this is going terribly what is this
cook terribly I mean I've been the
primary one talking okay and I haven't
been good you've been pretty what's
wrong what I said we've nothing's wrong
as you said what as long as you feel
like you got agree okay not super yeah I
feel like I got I feel like I was really
great we feel bad this was a really good
videos but to wrap it up and like Gary
that's not it's a editing right yeah
what you do I'm sorry
thank you that means you're weird about
it I'm sorry I didn't feel like I had a
groove you know yes this is your problem
not mine that makes it we I get it well
I didn't feel like I didn't know if you
had a groove and I feel like I agree I
felt driven okay
if you guys are needed the channel you
can subscribe today if you want to as we
don't do a good job here I John le
reasons to Jerry ah
I mean runs the blue house comm page
social media manager and uh yeah I guess
the videos over come do you can cut the
camera natural alright cut the camera